quando pediram pra eu falar obviamente é
o vínculo da inovação e da decepção é
teria que ser um setor que a gente está
aqui eu tô com o setor financeiro e isso
é muito bom porque o setor financeiro a
gente quase que depois de uma certa
idade todo mundo interage com ele que
está presente na vida de todos nós
quando as pessoas pensam em banco e
mercado financeiro a primeira coisa que
vem à cabeça é o lucro e só que as
coisas estão mudando isso mudando por
causa da tecnologia por causa da
digitalização
eu gosto de falar muito do exemplo que é
a questão do jogo de soma zero pra poder
ficar um pouco dessa realidade de lucro
e valor gerado
então quando a gente fala para as
pessoas que a gente lançou um produto
bancário num setor onde a gente tem os
maiores lucros corporativos do brasil
muita gente não sabe mas a maior
indústria do brasil não é commodity não
é entretenimento e lazer mas é assim com
serviços bancários na então como é que a
gente podia fazer um negócio diferente
eu falo muito que se uma pessoa pegar
por exemplo ilustra ele um telefone eu
gosto de falar do exemplo se eu pegar um
iphone por exemplo que custa mil dólares
nos estados unidos por exemplo chegar
num mercado no lugar onde temos escassez
desse produto e conseguir vender ele por
quatro mil dólares por exemplo o que a
gente está vendo aqui o vendedor teve um
resultado econômico contábil de 3 mil
dólares ou 3 mil reais aqui têm reais
oferecido a rim ea pessoa que comprou
está comprando um produto de valor
agregado de mil dólares na casa ela usar
as mesmas funcionalidades que por
exemplo americano comprou lá por mil
dólares e pagou 4 mil ela teve uma perda
de 31 então gente brinca aqui
esse é um jogo de soma zero quer dizer
você tem um resultado econômico gerado
positivo contábil não tem valor gerado
pela sociedade o que a gente percebe que
cada vez mais a digitalização as
empresas potenciais subjetiva
elas estão quebrando esse modelo então
quando a gente vê empresas como uber 11
em beijing um a amazon por exemplo elas
estão um pouco contra essa lógica que
elas querem e acho que o ponto central
da nossa do nosso bate-papo nossa pressa
elas querem elas podem fazer isso
através da tecnologia a tecnologia
digital como o pessoal falou está muito
na moda é meio né
então quando uma armação por exemplo é
ter obsessão de entregar um produto mais
rápido mais barato com a experiência
melhor na casa do cliente para isso ela
usa tecnologia e ferramentas digitais
ela consegue fazer um jogo que não seja
só a 0 ela tem uma geração de valor
absurdo para a sociedade e avançar um
pouco bom eu falo aqui é sobre esse jogo
de soma zero usando um exemplo prático
do dia-a-dia nosso e eu coloco o time
fome
vocês que são de belo horizonte não sei
se já passavam em frente à sede do banco
inter ea gente pensa que talvez seria
inimaginável missão financeira colocar
um telefone tudo pra falar quanto de
tarifas bancárias a gente devolveu para
os novos correntistas e quando a gente
fala sobre isso nas apresentações que a
gente faça um tanto no brasil quanto lá
fora as pessoas consultadas
e aí eu uso um pouco do do caixão do
jogo de soma zero
quer dizer a questão na digitalização
poder dar mais eficiência eu falo muito
dessa palavra o engenheiro civil
formação engenheiro ele tem ele tem essa
obsessão por eficiência quando você tem
um processo mais eficiente gera um valor
tão grande
você pode se dar o luxo de devolver
tarifas oferecer serviços mais baratos
do seu consumidor
então isso é um pouco da pegada nossa e
aí é quando a gente fala de as pessoas
às vezes pergunta pra gente quando que
nessas idéias fazer quando a gente tem a
idéia de fazer um banco gratuito digital
ou de fazer um transporte coletivo como
uber que não têm carros por exemplo o
maior exportador do mundo não tem um
carro sequer a gente fala gosto de falar
muito que eu me considero uma pessoa
criativa
a gente vê que a criatividade ela vem
muito bem
a cidade estava batendo um papo com o
nosso apresentador falando um pouco
sobre isso no momento em que a gente tem
uma dificuldade enfrenta um problema a
gente consegue ter as idéias criativas e
usar a tecnologia de digitalização para
resolver os problemas e quando a gente
quis criar esse conceito é de inovar no
mercado financeiro bancário brasileiro
isso foi mais ou menos há três anos
atrás e eu acho que é uma feliz
coincidência a gente está aqui hoje
falando dessa nesse projeto e falando um
pouco disso porque esse próximo slide
aqui que está aqui ele é talvez as
pessoas que trabalham com a gente saiba
mais o grande público sabe que foi um
pouco de fonte de inspiração pra gente e
essa essa palestra do site do senac
ela foi feito no ted acho que pelo menos
em são francisco enfim e onde houve essa
questão do do famoso caldo só conseguem
conhece isso acho que é um conceito
super legal onde o centro de tudo de
qualquer é propósito da empresa
você tem que do centro de qualquer
organização 70 o propósito
até brinco que a gente quer mineiro que
não é o ídolo mineiro é o ideal porque
né
então a gente tenha essa nova forma de
pensar como fazer um negócio inovador
subjetiva edital então a gente tem o
centro la com o propósito da companhia e
vou gastar um pouco mais de tempo aqui
no na questão do irã e do propósito
além dele está na parte mais importante
do gold circle
eu acho que é o que move a gente fazer
as coisas então quando a gente junta
aquela dificuldade que eu falei pra
vocês
a gente junta as ferramentas digitais
a tecnologia que é disponível está
disponível hoje para todo mundo e só
fazer um parêntese
eu falo que a gente vive no mundo hoje
onde as coisas são planas
é a tecnologia de de alto nível há o
serviço de dados abundantes está
disponível para a empresa pequena para a
pessoa que está começando por um grande
empresário com a empresa grande então
essa disponibilidade que a gente
conquistou com o avanço tecnológico das
últimas talvez duas décadas faz com que
seja possível então é quando a gente
junta isso caçá o acesso à tecnologia
acesso a essas
quinhentas e tenho um propósito muito
forte eu acho que isso é o mais
importante a gente fala que o sucesso de
qualquer empresa seja digital não tem
muito a ver com o propósito eu acho até
que a gente vive hoje o mundo gente
brinca um pouco meu louco porque é tudo
muito rápido muito dinâmico ea gente
fala que as empresas que vão ter é é um
ser perenes vão ter uma vida longa elas
têm que ter um propósito muito bem
definido ea gente achou nessa dessa
desse modelo do gol do sorondo excitação
do idt o propósito do nosso para o nosso
negócio a revolução bancária
então a gente é colocou como propósito
fazer uma revolução bancária no brasil a
gente vê que o brasil ele infelizmente
uma saúde precária para as pessoas que
têm menos condição uma educação mais
difícil e isso também é a realidade dos
serviços financeiros bancários então
esse é o propósito do nosso negócio eu
acho que qualquer empresa nessa gente
puder década longe qualquer empresa que
queira fazer alguma coisa diferente vai
ter os desafios daí que vão nascer essa
oportunidade irei que a gente vai por
criatividade para furar têm as
ferramentas disponíveis a digitalização
a tecnologia permite isso mas é preciso
que se tenha um propósito muito bem
definido
é interessante que quando você define
muito bem esse propósito você passa a
ter uma vantagem sobre outros
competidores que você tem ea gente fala
que no nosso próprio nosso propósito
revolução bancária pode parecer clichê
mas passa por ter o cliente em primeiro
lugar eu acho que no mundo hoje é
competitivo e onde as pessoas as
empresas têm acesso a tudo se você
realmente não tiver o propósito da sua
empresa oferecer algo melhor o seu
cliente
você vai está fora do jogo então se eu
voltar aqui um pouco pro preciso age se
você não tiver obsessão por entregar um
telefone que por mil dólares e vai dar o
melhor funcionalidade melhor uso das
melhores ferramentas se você quiser
cobrar mais porque só tem espaço pra
comprar mais seja porque temos escassez
do produto você entrou no mercado na
frente você vai ter uma empresa um
negócio que não é perene então
é bom depois a gente tem um real tão
pouco do que eu falei que ver como é que
você pega o propósito da sua empresa e
coloca ele no mercado é que se faz para
poder construir isso e aí na frente vou
mostrar um vídeo animado do desse gol de
um cerco para o nosso modelo onde os
bancários vão entender um pouco melhor
mas é um pouco do que eu já falei a
questão da tecnologia há um tempo atrás
talvez a vez dos negros com as coisas
eram menos acessíveis é você poderia
querer fazer um processo competitivo é
querer revolucionar uma indústria
qualquer seja aviação seja transporte e
se esbarravam muito na capacidade de
colocar isso em prática hoje com as
ferramentas digitais
a questão da digitalização as coisas
ficaram muito mais é parte de fazer
então por exemplo quando a gente pega é
um bem que tá hoje em 630 cidades mais
ou menos e os clientes dele interagem
100% com os motoristas através do
aplicativo porque grande parte da
população mundial estar munida com o
telefone como interface boa que é
relativamente barato você muda
completamente a a dinâmica do jogo então
essa questão do do rol o do design da
dessa revolução digital que a gente está
vivendo no mundo nos últimos 20 anos
talvez e por último é interessante que o
que o saibam se nem falar isso de
maneira bem legal depois dessa sugiro
que vocês possam ver o apresentação dele
só colocar até de sangue sendo que no
final das contas o outro que é o que
você faz é a coisa menos importante
então você está fazendo os serviços
bancários você está vendendo um telefone
da apple por sinal esse exemplo dodô
saibam se ele fala muito da apple é o
menos importante dizer é a consequência
e vai ter um produto bom você vai ter um
serviço melhor sem preocupar
especificamente no que você está fazendo
quer dizer começa de uma maneira muito
focado num propósito
acho que isso é fundamental é a origem
está no centro
o uso das ferramentas digitais
a tecnologia é a gente fica sor ganiza
ações policiais fazem isso muito bem
da escala pra isso melhora a vida das
pessoas eu acho que a gente fala muito
de da polícia
é a gente brinca que as empresas têm
toda razão social né às vezes a gente
esquece que a razão social mas não dá
conta de contas todas as empresas estão
uma sociedade para servir as pessoas
então tem isso muito em mente que você
tente melhorar um serviço que já atacou
as pessoas precisam que as pessoas estão
carentes no serviço que há uma intensa
esse propósito - cujas ferramentas
digitais que é como um ele falou no
final das contas no final do dia o outro
que se faz com que a empresa faça terá
produtos competitivos produtos bons
produtos inovadores
então acho que isso é um ego eu acho que
eu caísse porque se a origem do projeto
é subjetivo do banco itr
conseqüentemente o setor bancário
então agora precisa entender um pouco do
do aido raoni.com gente tenha a
revolução bancária no centro do que o
nosso propósito muito bem definido e eu
falo gente que aqui obviamente a gente
fala um pouco do projeto banco o inter
mais eu fico muito satisfeito de ver
outras empresas financeiras com esse
propósito muito bem definido é
infelizmente o setor financeiro e um
setor que foi um pouco retardatário
nesse nesse modelo de digitalização de
discussão por razões óbvias regulação
crise de 2008
mas eu fico satisfeito que a gente não
está sozinho nesse movimento a revolução
bancária e as pessoas perguntam pra
gente não quer dizer até o pessoal de
março no esporte mas é uma revolução
bancária não é uma revolução revolução
da palavra muito forte que às vezes não
combina com o setor financeiro
a gente fala que de fato é uma revolução
a gente fica satisfeito de ver no brasil
brasil tem muitas coisas boas a gente
acha que não é mais um é líder em muitas
coisas na índia muitas coisas legais
acontecendo aqui a gente vê que o esse
processo é um processo evolutivo da
revolução mesmo está acontecendo a gente
vê é setor financeiro é as pessoas
fazendo as coisas do mesmo jeito há 3
600 anos né sem colocar de fato o
cliente em primeiro lugar sem gerar
valor se a gente lembrar
ele primeiro slide do valor agregado
valor gerado então o movimento é feito
de maneira muito rápida muito intensa e
muda de maneira substancial a gente acha
que ele de fato um é um processo é de
revolução de evolução
ali para explicar um pouco melhor o raul
como a gente faz o coloque no caso
especificamente ser serviços financeiros
e digitais as ferramentas principais que
a plataforma de talca gente pra
interagir com os clientes para poder
trazer os clientes essa plataforma
estoque não o caso específico do banco
réu telefone é fundamental não e
voltando um pouco aquela questão do do
desafio da criatividade quando as
pessoas perguntam a de onde veio a idéia
de fazer um banco digital e tentar mudar
o setor bancário
eu falo que essas coisas não acontecem
no click ninguém acorda à noite o posto
de venda é maravilhosa as coisas vão
acontecendo mas de novo quando se
enfrenta um problema enfrenta um desafio
se acha solução e no nosso caso é o
problema em enfrentar é em sons
bancárias estabelecidas grandes e com um
impacto grande no país então a gente tem
que ser criativo então resolvemos ter a
plataforma de tal como porta de entrada
é a parte de inteligência de dados
fundamental gente eu acho que qualquer
empresa hoje exponent de crescimento
exponencial qualquer empresa que está se
digitalizando ela precisa usar muito bem
essa informação de dados
e eu falo que os dados hoje de novo
pegando aquela cara nunca foi das coisas
estarem mais aquecido os dados são
baratos e armazenar são baratos de
coletar com a questão digital você
consegue coletar isso bem então eu acho
que essa essa abundância de dados no
mundo hoje permite muita coisa quer
dizer quanto mais dados e tiveram o seu
cliente mais informação você tem melhor
se presta o serviço então quando robert
mandar um carro se passado sabe como é
que você gosta de é porque ele tem dados
por e todas então isso hoje é barato
fácil então a gente fala muito da da da
lei de muro não sei se quem conhece que
as coisas vão ficando esponencialmente
cada vez mais baratas baratas baratas
então armazenamento de dados passa por
isso eu falo a questão do crm
é essa fundamental no caso do banco
inter eu acho que qualquer empresa de
crescimento exponencial em qualquer
empresa é um pecado digital tem relação
com o cliente como um negócio muito
muito importante e eu falo que de novo
na hora que você tem a plataforma
digital para fazer um catálogo de tal
abundância de dados
a forma de interagir com seu cliente da
maneira correta no momento correto a
prover um serviço melhor ou um produto
ela fica muito mais fácil então no caso
dos serviços financeiros no brasil essas
três ferramentas nos famoso hall 8 como
a gente faz são fundamentais e por
último gente até pra tentar ficar aqui
dando um tempo eu falo que no final das
contas que fazendo analogia com que o
site não menos importante é o que a
gente faz
mas o que são serviços financeiros e é
um serviço tão na vida de todo mundo já
conhece então desde um empréstimo desde
um cartão de crédito desde um seguro de
investimento e é isso quer dizer que ele
começar uma empresa pensando no lucro
que vai ter no produto você tem que ver
qual é o propósito que você quer fazer
como você consegue impactará a vida das
pessoas o famoso gostei com dois dos
seus funcionários
use a transformação digital que a gente
está passando
ela está fazendo com que as coisas
fiquem muito mais disponíveis e o campo
fique muito mais aberto ou seja com um
pequeno empresário por um médio então dá
pra competir as coisas são mais fáceis
leve esse propósito de no caso nossa
revolução bancário revolução no
transporte no caso de forma muito séria
o uso dessas ferramentas no final das
contas essas empresas elas têm de
entregar produtos de mais qualidade e
produtos melhores para as pessoas e só
pra cá barragem que eu falo muito que às
vezes as pessoas perguntam um pouco
sobre a competição também é hoje é muito
competitivo principalmente para as
empresas de crescimento exponencial falo
que nesse caso é quando a gente vê
eu falei lá atrás que infelizmente a
gente não está sozinho nesse movimento
de revolução bancária de de
digitalização do setor financeiro e eu
falo que no final das contas obviamente
a empresa ganha um acionista a gente a
empresa listada mas o bacana quando a
gente vê que a sociedade ganhe
de novo a gente tem muito orgulho de
poder hoje está ajudando alguns milhões
de brasileiros a ter um serviço melhor
mais democrático mais fácil e está
fazendo junto com outros países estão no
final das contas acho que o grande
beneficiado dessa situação toda é o
brasileiro são as pessoas então isso
deixa a gente bastante feliz gado
[Aplausos]